[Música]
como marchas antigubernamentales en
argentina los manifestantes rechazan las
políticas de austeridad que se están
implementando para pagar la deuda con el
fmi y piden las ayudas como una renta
básica universal y un bono especial para
jubilados y trabajadores no registrados
ya fueron repatriados a méxico los
cuerpos de 16 de los migrantes que
murieron asfixiados en un camión en
texas de las 53 personas que hallaron en
el trailer 26 eran mexicanos el jueves
se realizaron sus honras curas
por primera vez en la historia de perú
la corte suprema autorizó una eutanasia
la muerte digna será paraná estrada
quien desde hace más de 30 años padece
una enfermedad incurable tenemos reporte
desde el inah
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
esta vez dedicadas al continente
americano mi nombre es maría clara calle
iniciamos en argentina donde hubo
protestas en contra del gobierno del
izquierdista alberto fernández los
manifestantes rechazan el
refinanciamiento de la deuda con el
fondo monetario internacional y piden
que el dinero de la deuda externa sea
invertido en programas sociales todo
esto en un momento en el que la
inflación del país alcanzó un 64 por
ciento anual crisis económica pobreza y
desempleo es lo que enfrentan miles de
argentinos que se volcaron a las calles
para exigirle un cambio en sus políticas
al presidente alberto fernández una
permanencia de mayo
el 50 de la población por debajo en la
línea de pobreza aumentan cada vez a los
porcentaje de indigencia una inflación
en los productos alimentarios del 8%
porque acaban de cambiar
a la ministra de economía que no ha
cambiado nada
los manifestantes buscan que el gobierno
apruebe una renta básica universal y un
bueno especial para jubilados y
trabajadores no registrados además
rechazan las medidas de austeridad que
anunció la nueva ministra de economía
silvina batakis con las que buscan
cumplir los pagos al fondo monetario
internacional- a quien le deben unos 44
mil millones de dólares
los manifestantes quieren que el dinero
que financia la deuda externa se destine
a los más pobres de argentina merece que
el pueblo en realidad salga decir
unificadamente en trabajadores ocupados
y trabajadores desocupados
esta receta del fondo que no podemos
seguir diciendo a la mente ya que no
podemos ir a la góndola y no poder
comprar y encima cuando vamos a poder
comprar no hay abastecimiento de
productos como pasa con el aceite con la
harina muchas veces con la azúcar la
inflación podría acercarse al 80 por
ciento este año según analistas además
conforme en los últimos datos oficiales
la pobreza afecta al 37 3% de los
argentinos el gobierno de panamá intentó
de manera fallida una solución a las
protestas que llevan más de una semana
en la capital el presidente de
laurentino cortizo instaló una mesa de
negociaciones pero la alianza pueblo
unido por la vida y la alianza nacional
por los derechos del pueblo organizado
que son las impulsoras de la huelga no
participaron ellas alegan que el
ejecutivo decidió unilateralmente las
condiciones del diálogo nuestro
corresponsal oscar sulbarán nos explicó
qué pasó con las conversaciones del
presidente de la república a laurentino
cortizo convocó a una mesa de diálogo
para este jueves
en esa convocatoria acudió el presidente
de la republica apoyo parte de su
gabinete también una comisión de la
asamblea nacional de diputados de una
representación de la iglesia pues el
gobierno solicitó que la iglesia fuera
mediadora en estos diálogos
durante el acto de instalación de esta
mesa de diálogo el presidente a la
república reconoció las protestas de los
ciudadanos sin embargo también denunció
que había infiltrados personas
personajes políticos infiltrados que
trataban de dañar los legítimos reclamos
de la población los grandes ausentes de
esta mesa de diálogo instalada por el
gobierno en la ciudad capital fueron los
representantes de las principales
organizaciones
gremiales y sindicales que llevan la
bandera de
de este conflicto el principal motivo
que ellos expusieron para no asistir es
que pedían que todo lo que se realizara
de ahora en adelante que fuese
consensuado están de acuerdo con un
diálogo pero creen que todo lo que se
deben avisar en torno al diálogo desde
la mediación hasta los temas debe
realizarse en forma consensuada
16 de los 26 mexicanos que fueron
encontrados muertos en un camión en el
estado estadounidense de texas ya fueron
repatriados sus familiares hicieron las
honras fúnebres el jueves y se espera
que nueve de los diez cuerpos restantes
sean transportados a mexico rafael pérez
nos cuenta
el silencio de la madrugada en san
marcos' de tequila pan en el oriente
mexicano era solo interrumpido por los
pasos de unas 100 personas se dirigían
al pie de la patrona espiritual de
mexico para recibir los cuerpos de tres
jóvenes migrantes hallados sin vida
dentro de un camión en el estado de
texas el pasado mes de junio
[Música]
los gritos de dolor retumbaron en la
noche
giovanni y misael de 16 años y ya ir de
19 dos hermanos y un primo que no podrán
cumplir sus sueños como las cosas están
subiendo de precio pues las cosas suben
pero el trabajo no les suben
pues por eso ellos tuvieron que salir a
buscar una mejor vida como yolanda otros
familiares se recibieron a sus seres
queridos
recordar las aspiraciones de los
difuntos es una manera de rendirle
tributo también para recordar los
peligros que afrontan al cruzar de
manera ilegal la frontera nosotros hemos
difundido en redes sociales una campaña
constante de que no se arriesguen
sabemos que la migración es un derecho
universal pero hay que hacerlo de manera
informada
y respetando los derechos humanos de
cada persona los primeros 16 cuerpos
llegaron desde el miércoles en aviones
militares la cancillería mexicana
informó otro vuelo para repatriar los
cadáveres restantes según reportes de
forenses 26 mexicanos murieron en el
remolque abandonado en texas de los
cuales 25 serán repatriados mientras el
dolor inundaba los hogares mexicanos
otro grupo intentaba cruzar el río
fronterizo entre méxico y eeuu en busca
de un futuro mejor al precio necesario
el hallazgo de 53 cuerpos sin vida en la
parte trasera de un camión fue el evento
más trágico en la historia reciente de
la migración rumbo norte
a na estrada es la primera persona en
perú y por ahora la única que tendrá una
eutanasia autorizada por la corte
suprema con cuatro votos a favor el
máximo órgano judicial le permitió la
muerte digna a esta psicóloga de 45 años
quien padece una enfermedad incurable
sin embargo la sentencia sólo aplica
para su caso y no abre la eutanasia en
el país desde el imán a nuestro
corresponsal francisco zacarías tienen
la información
la corte suprema de perú autorizó por
primera vez la realización de una
eutanasia el tribunal reconoce al
derecho de una muerte digna a estrada
una mujer que padece una enfermedad
incurable y progresiva desde los 12 años
la sentencia no faculta la posibilidad
de más eutanasia si solamente se
autoriza a estrada el derecho de decidir
el momento final de su vida este fallo
ha sido calificado de histórico por la
defensoría del pueblo el organismo
además señaló que todavía queda por
resolver los procedimientos relacionados
al protocolo médico para articular la
realización de la otan asia que aún no
dispone de consenso de los cuatro votos
de la corte suprema- el voto del
presidente del tribunal no coincide
sobre la forma en que debe ejecutarse
por esta razón la corte ha programado
audiencia para el próximo jueves 22
donde una jueza dirimente decidirá sobre
los aspectos del protocolo la activista
ana estrada venía litigando desde hace
cuatro años con el estado peruano para
obtener la autorización a poseer una
muerte digna hoy la justicia peruana dio
el primer paso para hacer realidad suena
deseo un deslizamiento de tierra en
colombia sepultó una escuela y al menos
tres estudiantes fallecieron ariane
villacorta nos cuenta qué pasó
es un día triste para el departamento
colombiano de antioquia tres niños
murieron y dos están hospitalizados
consecuencia de un deslizamiento de
tierra que se llevó a una escuela en la
que se encontraban 22 menores las
autoridades locales enviaron sus
condolencias
nos duele en el alma al fallecimiento de
anna sophia andrea y alexander tres
angelitos que partieron demasiado pronto
y nos dejan un vacío infinito
ofrecemos acompañamiento psicosocial a
sus familias y a la comunidad educativa
nuestras oraciones están con el pueblo
de andés más de 200 personas entre
población civil y entidades operativas
atendieron la emergencia en está parto
x los organismos de socorro se
encuentran ayudando a esta institución
educativa donde una luz de tierras
sorprendió a unos jóvenes a unos
estudiantes que estaban recibiendo
clases en esta institución educativa se
encuentra de todo método
cómo pueden ustedes retroexcavadoras de
fuente en la parte alta ayuda alto
rescatar a los niños con vida de acuerdo
con las informaciones que se tienen
hasta el momento hubo un represamiento
de aguas en la parte alta de la escuela
lo que podría haber originado la
tragedia esto se produce un día después
de que dos personas murieran tras el
derrumbe de un caserío en una aldea
cercana a medellín la capital antioqueña
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]